one of the fundamental features of a
prototype is that it acts vaguely like
the final lap when it's interacted with
but is much simpler to make this means
that when we build a prototype we need
to think about interaction points an
interaction point is anywhere then the
user might press scroll or type in order
to interact with your app by identifying
the interaction points for your app you
will identify where you need to link
screens together and what work you need
to do to build a prototype for low
fidelity prototype we only need to deal
with interaction points that will move
the user between screens not interaction
points that will allow them to input
content for example let's take a look at
our calendar in to-do list app this app
has a floating action button or fab
which we can expect users to touch and
on the screen that opens it has a number
of other options we can expect users to
try to interact with each of them in the
final app but since they don't add
another screen we don't need to deal
with that functionality here just yet on
our menu screen each item leads to a new
screen fewer menu items means fewer
screens to build but also a reduced
functionality finding a balance there is
vital we don't want to remove any core
functionality in order to have fewer
interaction points but you can probably
go without a terms and conditions option
in your loaf I prototype